I'm not really in a position to
criticize once you bought one green but
I am this place isn't even breaking even
and yet berries forking out four and a
half grand a week just on staff are they
service it's no way to run a successful
business berries in love with you oh no
no but they're no he's in love with your
food um yeah I see you like it yeah he's
never gonna be your critic and what I've
got to understand is where is your
critic coming from ah I was telling you
to stop that's it send it when I think
it's all right Tom said she didn't more
Go Go no wonder he's foods over the top
now I want to see how he runs his
kitchen
now pull
foursomes as every played journeys
around the kitchen
each iv7 chefs adds another flourish and
all this unnecessary fussing is wasting
time and money
hurry up there's so many hands were
going on round the kitchen the plate is
that normal for the go-around can they
not finish anything then Jesus my sauce
the simple setup though they need my
sauce okay you put the plate on the
degree and I thought okay up Tony's
missing no no no it's okay it's okay
sorry
because I was done 250 and we cooked in
the last and to half the houses and ten
sorry please I felt that I wanted to
just say stop what you've got at the
beginning was just enough for me
first lesson see my senior simple
because the ingredients you've got aa
phenomenal he needs to let his food
speak for itself
his approach feels outdated and
pretentious is it easier maybe cook a
dish I heard like cook the scallops and
look at the difference and then go
through it together that way
right I wish we do scholars um no no
whatever um I've got she seems to do
okay
was it guest tonight and I'd be with you
okay
if the ration was full I could
understand his arrogance but it's
hemorrhaging cash and no one seems to
care it's almost like and the barricades
are up and nothing's gonna get through
because all I want to do is do a dish
together and look at a different stage
you were taken out to make it before
peanuts but it doesn't seem to sink in
are you going to be part our team just
let me in been hard-asses
yeah nice but winning in this situation
with over complex food no direction I'd
[ __ ] grab that kind of insight wasn't
issues